so welcome back to the second set of
lectures on learning convex optimization
we will have the sector thanks for the
introduction yeah I am Nick alone from
Milan I'll talk about online learning
online convex optimization so I have 49
slides and this is these are not meant
for this lecture but for both lectures
so we'd be sort of a nice to you
actually I've done it not to be nice to
you but because I'm lazy in brightest
lights but and some of these lights are
cannot dance
but there will be time to interact and
you know ask questions and hopefully it
won't be too hard and these are not
really classroom style slides they're
definitely classy slides but not
classroom right because I'd like to you
know rather rather than teaching at like
like to infuse people into working on in
this area so maybe I will convey some
ideas some of them will be detailed with
proofs as some other will be left a
little bit sketchy so we try to give you
sort of a broad pictures I mean there
are there's a lot of stuff there are a
lot of directions results settings I'll
try to give you sort of a wider view and
zoom in some interesting technical
aspects whenever I feel like it's
appropriate okay this is the plan is
very informative new you well the game
here is that you have to guess the title
the titles of the books and you don't
have to do it now I mean I don't want
you to show off your culture but that's
fine okay yeah this I mean if you were
born in the 50s probably you have this
in your in your house not this one in
particular but to the other guy
beautiful and as it drawn pictures yes
okay so the idea is basically I will
start connecting with what Elliot did in
the morning this is just by sheer luck I
didn't
but it turns out to be perfect and then
I will move to the experts
bandit kind of scenario and we will
spend the rest of the morning on that
and in the afternoon if you are if you
come back you will see something about
the online convex optimization scenario
okay good so we start with the the
machine learning so actually okay right
so Ellie told us this morning
the some of the so-called standard
modern of standard model of machine
learning which is the statistical
learning okay
and this is was introduced by back that
Nick this is a picture of APNIC and
maybe a few years ago and this is
basically you know it's basing on idea
that learning algorithm is is a mapping
from data sets to predictive models okay
and so you have some set of predictive
models and predictive models are maybe
classifiers or regressor or they map in
general they will map data instances to
labels princess binary classification
which you can do with like in spam
detection or something else and the
learning algorithms are again as I said
are these mappings from training data
into into predictive models and you can
think of a super vector machine or or
about a neural network as a typical
example of a neural network along with
the training algorithm as a typical
example of a learning algorithm
associated with the different with the
certain architecture okay so what you
want to do here the way you you work you
analyze it you study
machine learning is you want to evaluate
some notion of risk which will tell you
how good is your training model with
respect to some given loss function
which is possibly capturing the
interesting apps aspects of the problem
okay
so now the idea here is how do now
should I define risk risk is is
something that will has to be associated
with some data model only whenever you
have a data model and a loss function
you can talk about risk and right so now
we can look at the different notions of
risk one is what we saw this morning
which is the statistical risk usual
notion of statistical risk so in in a
statistical risk you assume that the
training set is drawn from some unknown
and fixed distribution in an independent
way is a very nice and comfortable
assumption and now you can now this the
training set is a statistical sample now
you can apply your learning algorithm to
the to the to the training set which is
just a physical sample to get the model
and then you can look at the expected
loss of this training model on a test
example which is drawn by the same
distribution and if you take
expectations may be with respect to both
draw the draw of the training set and
the test example you get the notion of
risk okay at least average risk with
respect to the to the draw of the
training set okay so this is the the
bread and butter of statistical learning
theory and this is a kind of notion that
we want to bound control using
Rademacher
or vc-dimension however this is not the
only possible way in which you can
phrase a study and reason about machine
learning okay for instance you may
wonder what happens if I refuse because
on philosophical grounds I refuse to
assume that there is some iid
distribution for which data is drawn
okay can i still can I still develop a
theory of learning without using
statistics okay so people have done that
and I'm going to talk about this exactly
this alternative model of risk which I
like to call sequential risk maybe I'm
the only one who calls it that way
you can call it any way you like so if
data suppose now the data are not you
know they're not drawn from some
distribution there's an emitter II
sequence of data in the individual
sequence of data this generate generated
by is being generated by some
unspecified mechanism so now what can
you say right you still have your
algorithm a and your agar is good at the
generative models whenever you feed it
with data so what you can do is you can
feed the to the Algren okay so you want
to take in a can't want to see some
learning happening here so you can feed
the growing prefix prefixes of the data
sequence to the or Al Green okay and
then whatever you do that you will get a
model and then you can check how's the
performance on the model on the next
example in the data sequence which you
see which you view interpret as a test
example right and you can sum up this
these losses you can sum them up and
maybe you can average them if you like
you know but it's definitely you want to
see some something happening whenever
when you you you start feeding longer
longer prefixes of the data sequence to
the Al Green you would like to see some
some learning meaning that this this
sasame should not draw the same rate but
should flatten out okay
is that clear no it's given it's an
individual sequence I am NOT I'm not
messing up it's it's it's someone is
spitting out this sequence and I am just
feeding one by one okay so any more
questions here good so here is another
coordinate right so now yeah we can we
can again try to fix our thoughts on a
statistical learning and get inspiration
there so one key notion
that is a combination of risks in
statistical learning is that what's
called the variance error the variance
error tells you that whenever your
algorithm draws pics model chooses
models from a given class a fixed class
of models may be neural networks with a
certain number of hidden units and a
certain architecture then you can talk
about the best model the best sorry yes
the best model in the class that is the
model that minimizing the risks in your
class given the data distribution they
fix that and unknown data distribution
and then you can look at what is the
difference between the risk of the
algorithm that you're using which is
picking mountain from the same class and
the best possible the risk of the best
possible model in the class this
difference is going to be positive or
may be 0 if you're lucky because it's
not picking he's going to pick models
from the same classes as this infimum
here ok so this is what we look in a
statistical learning and it turns out
you can define just like you did with
risk you took statistically the risk and
you define it what you define it you
define its equation risk now you can
define something which is the analogous
of variance error in statistical
learning and you call it regret so
regret is the gain the same thing but
you you don't take risks you take
sequential risks and now you look at the
difference between the cumulative loss
on the data sequence you're given in an
incremental way of the best model in
your class and the cumulative loss of
the sequence of models that your
algorithm is spitting out as you feed it
more and more data examples ok so this
is going to be again you can divide by T
if you like to normalize somehow but
this is something that will be will tell
you how good is on an arbitrary data
sequence and B 3 data sequence how good
is your Algren in finding out the what
is the the the over at the offline over
model in the class now you see this
quantity could become a potentially
negative because here your your your
agony is free to change a model at each
time step okay but on the other hand we
don't have a probability to rely upon so
things can get really nasty if the data
sequence is is you know is designed in a
certain malicious way okay oh right so
now one thing that is nice whenever you
think about learning in this way now it
you you end up with a very incremental
and the local way of learning in which
you know what you do you you have some
current model which is the model that
you trained it so far on the data that
you've seen and that you get some next
data element and you test your model on
that next next data element you find out
that maybe suck so you want to adjust it
a little bit and you make an update and
this update it's a local optimization up
there because it will be based on that
the state the previous state which is
the which is compressing all the data
you'll see so far and the next data
element that you see so it hasn't to be
this way you can memorize the entire
sequence you saw and you can rerun every
time at the algorithm from scratch but a
more and a nicer way of designing is
actually to go to a local optimization
view and for just have your the the
current model to represent the data
source you saw you see so you saw so far
and then just to perform a local update
and incremental update in order to add
the further information to your
algorithm so this is the way we will
design and we'll think about this the
algorithms in the online setting so they
will perform a sequence of small
adjustment to a current model and then
we'll learn this way so right and I will
write this many times the goal here is a
still to control regret
which will be you know the difference
between cumulative loss of your model
sequence and the cumulative loss of the
best model in your set okay questions
cool
good so oops
so now you can see we can we can view
this process as a game and this is
convenient this is reasonable because we
are not making assumptions on the way
the data are generated so we can make
just you know just think that there's
some adversary that is generating the
data and trying to hurt us or maybe not
that we don't know but it's definitely
games are a reasonable way to to view a
reasonable setting to cast problems like
online learning sequential learning okay
so so what are the players there's a
player that is generating predictors and
that there are some opponent is
generating the data that is trying you
know to throw off the predictor and make
it incur a large a large accumulative
loss okay so now we can we move to the
second part and we can draw from leisure
instead of drawing from statistics we
can draw from game theory to get some
ideas and the like to mention here James
Shannon and David Blackwell who were
pioneers in the study of many things and
among others the theory repeated games
so and if you play a game repeatedly you
can view it as a learning problem
because maybe your opponent is just dumb
and if you repeat the game over and over
you can you can learn the way the
opponent behaves and you know make a and
have a much larger payoff that the
payoff you could have gotten if you had
played the game just once okay so let me
be a little bit more clear about it you
know just think of a simple zero-sum
two-person game and you have a low row
player which will be our learner
we'll be a column player which will be
the opponent you know if you play if you
if you know you you play the game one so
then okay you have minimize theory which
telling you that you should you should
draw your action your roll action from a
distribution which is minimax and this
will be good against any opponent
especially against the Maximian opponent
which will the one that will cause you
the maximum expected loss which is the
value of the game however you know if
you if you play maybe you you know if
you if you play the game more than once
then there's a whole new scenario
opening up for you because you know
maybe this magic is huge right there are
many many columns and you cannot compute
the minimax the strategy because it's
too expensive you don't have time or
maybe you don't know the matrix the
matrix is not completely known to you is
not accessible to you so you cannot
compute the minimax strategy
or maybe you know it maybe it's not good
that to compute the minimize strategy
because your opponent is dumb but and
you can have it expected the losses much
smaller if you just apply a game a few
times and find out that your opponent is
just stupid put a stupid meaning that
the data sync reset your observing is
actually easy to learn so you don't have
to use a hard strategy you can tailor
you can adapt your strategy to the
actual strategy to the extra battle
sequence is a sequence that you are
observing which corresponds to the
strategy of the opponent is in this game
theoretic view all right okay so oh some
more pictures these are this is bloody
Volker and Manfred Mann Frank is is in
Santa Cruz you can go and visit him is
very nice guy and in London I think and
so they they were sort of a maybe
unconsciously not because they were
unconscious but they were not aware of
this fact they may be good
they sort of picked up this idea I mean
you know it's science doesn't gonna see
in a straight line you're these
epiphanies and then you found out that
you're just you know redoing theory that
was done that 50 years before and then
you and you you connect to reconcile so
then they say okay we can formulate this
repeated game as a sequential prediction
problem because now I can think of a
game matrix with you know as many
columns as you like which is the horizon
of the game that you're going to play
and your adversary is just making up
these columns for you and revealing this
counts one by one so this corresponds to
the opponent's move which is this so the
opponent is like making up a column and
in the in the data in the loss matrix of
the game as at the time as the game goes
on so you will pick some raw and the
opponent will reveal the column which is
it it's move at time T so you can view
this as if I okay and now I can call you
know I can call the raw and and and my
play is the loss which I had the time T
whenever I played the action I sub T
okay so it's a sequential prediction
problem with the same time varying loss
function and the function is time
varying because you have a data that
define in different losses so the loss
at time T will be defended by the data
that you saw that comes up at time T so
maybe it will be defined by the label of
the data instance at empty okay I will
make this a little bit clearer so okay
so now we can get to exit to the experts
game so we can come up with with a sort
of general elapses framework that is the
sort of a standard reference framework
to study sequential decision problems in
a completely abstract way if you like so
you have n actions which corresponds to
the number of rules in your game matrix
and you have some unknown deterministic
assignment or losses to the actions now
here to make things simple I'm assuming
that the adverse
is you know your adversary is laying
down all these columns for you without
revealing them and it as you play the
game it will reveal the columns one by
one so the game is goes like this these
are your own actions these are the roles
that you can pick and you will pick some
role it will have some loss of sanity to
it and you will incur that loss and then
you will observe the loss that you
incurred and you will will observe the
losses of the actions you didn't pick
which corresponds to you know getting to
see every after each play you getting
you're getting to see the the whole
column of the matrix for that time step
alright so now now what we want to do
okay suppose that this losses are some
from bounded the interval between 0 1 so
now if we look at the regret and the
regret again is the cumulative loss that
we experienced by playing a different a
different action at it each time as
opposed to the smallest possible loss I
could have gotten by playing the single
best action throughout the game and
since this this these things are bounded
there now this thing can grow at most
linearly with time so we say that we
learn whenever we can get this sub linor
and we're interested in a precise rate
in the precise dependency on the
parameters of the game and the
parameters of the game here are really
time the number of columns and the
number of actions or the number of rows
okay so you can come up with a lower
bound that just by assuming that losses
are independent conflicts for all the
actions so you just fill out a random
matrix with conflicts fair coin flips
and now you can immediately see that any
player strategy will have like eight
over two losses your one loss and you
know it's completely blind there's
nothing to learn here there's no
structure however just by random
statistical deviation there will be some
expert meaning a row in this random
matrix which will have with high
probability will have a loss which is a
standard
smaller than the average loss okay and
if you do your computation precisely you
see that for large N and T you will have
this rate here okay so this is what you
can prove as a lower bound whenever the
game is completely you know is actually
done in a stochastic way so what we can
prove is that we can match this lower
bound that not only for stochastic
losses but for any adversary assign it
losses okay and this is done with this
very simple strategy which called hedge
and the idea is that you have to use
randomization because your sequence is
adversarial and so you want to pick an
action with a probability proportional
to the total loss of the action up to
now which you can compute because you
observe the losses of all actions okay
and so you you give it a overwhelmingly
high probability of picking the action
that did the best so far
historically but you also give some
nonzero probability of picking actions
that maybe were kind of bad but might
get better in the future and we will say
something about the proof I'm already
running whoo okay so you can prove that
if you pick your it in the right way you
actually match the upper bound for any
finite number of actions and for any
time horizon and this is including
constants and you can also have dynamic
choices which spare you from knowing the
horizon of the game that will only lose
a small constants with respect to this
bound okay so this was done a number of
times in game theory in information
theory and in computer science
maybe computer science got the right
constants and the right dependencies
okay and and and the algorithm is also
the simplest to do male I think it's
it's the simplest possible algorithm you
can think of good so now one variant
which is very natural there's been a
heavily studied is the so called non
stochastic bandit problem and the
difference is that here is just like
before but now you get a lot less
information because whenever the player
picks
action it will only observe the loss of
the action that is that it has picked
all the other losses will be there but
unknown to the player and the printer is
still competing at the against the best
offline action but now it gets a lot
less information here but you know
sometimes the life is just good and that
the same thing basically still works you
just have you know you cannot compute
the correct losses for each actions
because we have partial information so
you can just use estimates importance of
weighted estimates so you divide that
whenever you pick a loss you divide that
the loss whenever you pick an action you
divide the observatory bility of a
picking backed action otherwise you just
stick a 0 into the vector so you have a
vector of losses at each time step which
are which has hardly a nonzero component
and this nonzero component is as a
larger value than the observed loss
because you want to compensate for that
many times you put a 0 instead of
putting the right loss so it's very easy
to see that in expectation this is an
unbiased estimator okay if you did make
a conditional expectation with respect
to P that the drawing of your action see
if this is the right expected value and
that the variance can be nicely bounded
by the reciprocal of the probability so
now you can go through you can do the
proof and the proof of or the bandit
case actually gets the the experts bound
you saw before as a byproduct and that
there is a very little algebra that it
takes you here actually so very little
algebra I teach it in undergrad and they
I did this they tell me they get it I
never know so right so you get up to
here so you can bound a regret by this
constant term and this term here which
contains the variances times the
probabilities and this is just this is
called the bandit magic this product
it's it's a branded name you cannot use
it but you can pay royalties to me and
right so we know that this the very
respect that the variance is upper
bounded by the reciprocal the
probability and so well this is actually
the same this is the same guy because
the probability of the loss is observe
it in the bandit is the probability that
the action
is picked so this will get cancelled so
you are summing up once and you're
summing up T's and you get N and T and
then you pick your ETA and you get this
nice thing which is you know just a
little worse than what you had had for
the for the experts because in the
experts you didn't have this term here
but you have a matching lower bound and
if you care about this log term I don't
but these two guys did that actually
they came up with a very nice an elegant
a solution I'm trying to make up now
because I'm saying that impairment is a
very nice result
and so you can have a slightly more
complicated strategy and get a matching
lower bound and okay you can get the
experts bound here because in the
experts the probability did observe the
loss is always won because you observe
all losses so now what the hell here is
here is one and now you summing up the
probabilities and you get one so you'd
instead of having a NTU I just have T
and then you tuner you get your nice
experts bound okay nice
so may variations variations are
interesting won't go into a lot of
details so the first variation is is the
following what is okay we you start with
game theory but in game theory we know
you know that verse Aries are nastier
than here they're not bleed is they not
lay down losses beforehand and then late
lot let us draw draw our pennies our
coins they actually will adapt to the
outcomes of our past randomization so
now we can think of a situation in which
the loss of an action at time T will
depend maybe on the past M place of the
player okay let's give it some memory
here okay and one example were very
natural example is bandit with the
switching cost so whenever you stick to
the same action you just pay the loss of
detection but whenever you switch action
then you pay an extra unit loss okay and
you in order to debate the adverse has
to keep a memory of one because it has
to remember what you played in the last
act in the last step
okay so this is an instance of this more
general framework
and so now you can define regrets you
can define a new oblivious regret which
is just what we saw before we just have
the same thing but we now have losses
here that are the actual losses with
other dependencies now this looks a
little bit funny because what we had
before we could view this as the
cumulative loss that the player could
have gotten by playing the same you know
the single best strategy all the times
but here now it doesn't have an
interpretable view because you see here
there's a contamination between I and
what the player actually what the player
did in the past and that this so you
cannot do this counterfactual reasoning
anymore because right so what you would
like to have here I'm just just showing
this so that it becomes clearer you
would like to have this thing here okay
what happens if I actually play
consistently the single best action this
will be my cumulative loss not that but
this okay so this is a right quantity to
look at and to study in the context of
non oblivious opponents this is also
useful if you want to prove game
theoretic properties like correlated
equilibrium minimizing regret properties
but I'm not talking about that so this
has some uses but it somehow is more
restricted this is kind of the right
thing to study whenever you have an Ono
blizzard bursary not yes up to twenty
minus one yes the outcome of the cantos
is up to time t minus one sure that's
the essence of otherwise it is oblivious
okay so well xp3 is just amazing and not
because I'm a quarter of the paper but
because it's it's a very versatile green
and and Peter our is another quarter and
you have throwing the rubbish a period
two other quarters this this paper is a
funny story but I won't tell it here but
okay so what happens so if you have this
the kind of a silly regret XP tree will
get you the same bound even if the
adversary knows the outcome of the past
coins Wow and the one open question here
is whether we cannot prove actually the
more sophisticated Galgo in the shaving
off the log factor we can prove it in
this case for no no beliefs adversary so
it's not knowing whether this factor is
necessary it's again it's a log factor
if you like then it's for the policy
regret things are much harder and it
turns out that this turns out that
there's a phase condition here so the
you don't have this nice sort of a sort
of a law of large numbers kind of square
root of rate square root of T rate but
you have a T to the 2/3 rate because
you're looking out at this more
complicated more sophisticated notions
notion of them regret and your
adversary's more powerful and and
unfortunately it's the kind of a silly
strategy that achieves this upper bound
that you cannot do much anything much
clever proving a law and matching lower
bound is much tougher you have to you
cannot do a simple iid process to
generate losses you have to use a
dependent process to generate losses and
there's a beautiful paper by offered
aquel tumor car and you've all Perez who
explain explains how which explains how
to do it and this is optimal up up to
log factors okay so they get them a
matching lower bound
optimal factors okay this is all for any
constant memory of the diversity at
least one okay and if it's strictly
bigger one you'll have also the same
lower bound and the same upper bound in
the experts case in full information
case so that's cool I have yeah ten
minutes nine minutes left right a little
more yeah you know all right
so other variations this is also very
nice it's called partial monitoring this
is generalization of bandits so suppose
that you are selling t-shirts on a
website
and you know every customer comes and
you have dynamic pricing policy and so
you're trying to make trying to get the
to guess the value that the customer has
for your t-shirt and to set the price
matching the value of the customer the
problem here is that you know the
customer won't ever tell you oh I
actually I could have bought this
t-shirt at a much higher price they
won't tell you now so now what what you
get actually get is a feedback is not
the losses so suppose now the losses is
the following this is the price this is
the value for the customer and this is
the price that you the posted price for
for that customer so for instance if you
have a price of two and the customer has
about had a value for you're losing two
bucks because you could have sold it to
the same customer as the need for four
dollars instead of two dollars okay and
if you price it to and the customer to
the value of one then you're losing some
constant some constant a number because
your your stock is you know keeping the
stock around is a costly whatever
however the feedback is only what you
get is the feedback is only sold not
sold right so what you do here can you
minimize your get in this situation when
your feedback and differs from the loss
you want to minimize regret with the
loss but you don't see the loss you see
it's just binary feedback you can you do
that so there's an okay multi-armed
bandit in special case in which loss and
feedback metrics are the same so you
play something you see and and then you
exactly see what should be the loss of
what you played okay so you're
generalizing that scenario so there's a
beautiful theory and there are several
papers just mentioning here some authors
Gabbar Bartok and now Google Dean Foster
now the Amazon david pal now to Yahoo
and Sasha rattling and Chavez Safari
their academics still
maybe maybe not now so and they have a
constructive characterization and
meaning master threat for any pair of
loss feedback metrics and there's gap
theory here so there's the gap theorem
there's a beautiful phenomenon that
basically there are only three possible
rates for any choice of loss and the
feedback matrix either you have is a
game like bandits in which you can get
your square root t regret I'm ignoring
dependencies on the other parameters of
the game there are hard games in which
like the dynamic pricing game in which
you get T to the 2/3 and there are
impossible games in which you know the
the feedback metric is doesn't give you
useful information in order to minimize
your loss and there you'll get is linear
there are no other rates here that's
pretty amazing and this is not trivial
I mean it's and I I'm not the court or
indeed so so it's um it's a very
naturally it's very very natural
unfortunately the algorithms are kind of
kind of things you would don't want to
run unlike XP tree or hedge okay cool
what has do we have here okay okay we
are heading towards the the after lunch
session so now I would like to I would
like to channel you towards the the
kingdom on a Vaughn line convex
optimization and I will do that in a
gentle way and so the first thing I
would like to see is just to view this
online prediction with expert advice as
an equivalent in an equivalent way so
now again we are expert we are doing the
experts game and we have a full
information everything is known we
everything in all apart from the future
so we no losses of all things you could
have played but we didn't and so we can
you know we can just assume that we are
actually not playing an action but we
are because we are actually what we are
scored with is this spected regret so we
can just assume we are playing
randomization in your here is in the
full information game is not important
because you have full information okay
so you can just assume that you're not
playing a single action material
the probability that's erection
appointed the simplex and then you incur
some linear loss which is that the
expectation of the probability with the
LOS vector this is something you can
compute right and then you can help you
do your little updates and you're happy
your observed a loss gradient which is
because it's an interaction is a leaner
loss you you observe the loss factor
which is the gradient of the leaner loss
okay and so you can think just for the
sake of it because it's not really
useful that you're competing against the
best point in the simplex okay so that's
your this your class of strategies
you're competing against but because the
loss is leaner this is just saying that
you're competing with the best corner of
the simplex it's say it's a convex it's
a simplex with the with the linear loss
so you're competing with a corner which
is again the best axis the single best
action so you're not gaining anything
here
you're just shifting your representation
you know in a game in which the game is
now you play a point from a convex set
and your square your scored with some
loss that is maybe linear maybe not and
then you observe the gradient of the
loss okay now you can keep these
ingredients in your mind the ends and
and get to this light which is not
really
why is there no okay this is just to
remind you that this analysis can be
useful if you're good two to four up the
machine learning applications because
this is this is somehow I said it again
I said it before you can view opponents
move as value or labels to sign it to
observations categories or documents
okay
and so the observations and the labels
are defining your losses and then you
can formulate an online learning and
online learning problem as a game
between the player which is choosing
some maybe vector of coefficients of a
model and from a linear space and the
opponent is choosing
from the data point the current data
point and then you want to measure
regret against with respect to the best
element in the linear space so the best
possible model in your model class so
okay this is the idea that this is sort
of a way of thinking this equation any
problem has abstractions of real
learning problems and I am done for this
first part and thanks for your attention
the ones that you don't there and the
one that you get T to the box yes what
is the difference in terms of the
feedback that you receive between the
second answer
well but it's a you can't think of it of
feedback matrices that are just you know
totally a color random they're not
totally that they don't they're not
correlated with thee you can it's easy
to get a linear regret here right
because the loss Maitre D' the feedback
matrix can be completely uncorrelated
with the loss it's actually it's very
comical related it's very much
correlated in the pressing case and just
like in the revealing action case the
revealing action case in which is the
case in which we have one action that
tells you the that allows you to see the
losses of all other actions but you pay
unit loss every time you check it so if
you you can design again a feedback
matrix which whenever you play detection
you have lots of one but you see the
losses of all other actions and then
whenever you play a different action you
only see the loss of that maybe you
don't see any loss revealing game and
and then there now a dynamic pricing is
is a little bit similar they will have
the same rate dynamic pricing has the
same rate as a reading game T to the 2/3
and that here it's kind of easy to see I
mean it's easy because this is a full
rank matrix so you can basically design
an estimator in which you reconstruct
the lost metric by inverting the
feedback matrix because it's full rank
so it will contain enough information to
reconstruct to estimate in an importance
weighted the way all the entries of your
loss matrix is not a bad situation this
is dynamic pricing dynamic pricing in in
the banded situation you have the bandit
magic the bandit magically what buys you
the first rate okay
you offer a price and and the customer
let's say why is it nothing else reveal
this say that because of the matrix
invertible and
invertibility you can get that you can
reconstruct yes you can retract it
exactly yeah this these two things are
known of course otherwise you cannot do
anything so you know these two matrices
but you know do not know what are the
the the strategies the YT which are the
columns here okay yeah there was another
question you can you know each of the
three categories you are no much
supplies will be squares of T - yes you
can compute it you can complete it yeah
activities